[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
en directo américa de france 24 por
supuesto como todas las mañanas en
nuestro programa con daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida ya a viernes ya nos
vamos a descansar hasta el próximo lunes
día merecido descanso que tenemos
después de estas semanas que después de
que empezó esta invasión de rusia ha
sido
muy dura para informarlos es viernes y
lo sabemos y lo sabemos así que están
los precios mundiales de los alimentos
marcaron récord históricos eso tiene que
ver como lo estábamos comentando con la
guerra claro raúl muy buenos días pues
lastimosamente para mucha gente a comer
se está volviendo un lujo porque según
las organizaciones de naciones unidas
para la alimentación y la agricultura
que es la fao el índice mundial de
precios en marzo se situó en su nivel
más alto desde que iniciaron registros
en 1990 debido en gran medida a la
guerra en ucrania y es que rusia y
ucrania son los principales exportadores
de trigo de maíz de cebada de aceite de
girasol entre otros y lo envían por el
mar negro la invasión de moscú a su
vecino desde hace seis semanas pues está
estancado estas exportaciones la favor
raúl analiza mensualmente el precio
general de todos los productos básicos
alimentarios y cinco subgrupos los vamos
a ver el aumento generales del 12 6 por
ciento de los precios en marzo si lo
comparamos con febrero y los cereales y
los aceites vegetales subieron un 17 y
un 23% respectivamente esto en apenas un
mes un alza de la que no se escapan los
otros grupos como lo son los lácteos la
carne y el azúcar con repuntes que van
del 3% al 7% y danny también la que está
generando la escasez de un producto muy
particular de qué estamos hablando por
raúl podrá sonar muy escatológico pero
mire el estiércol se está convirtiendo
en un insumo bastante deseado entre los
agricultores y es que desde que inició
la guerra los precios de los
fertilizantes comerciales alcanzaron
precios récord frente a esa escasez
mundial de fertilizantes ya que rusia es
uno de los principales proveedores pues
más productores están llamando a la
puerta de los granjeros quienes por años
hay que decirlo han tratado de mostrar
los beneficios
estiércol como abono para los cultivos
eeuu es un ejemplo de hecho mire quienes
antes pagaban para que se llevaran los
desechos de sus animales como vacas y
cerdos han encontrado un negocio
secundario fértil vendiendo los a los
productores de cereales y de otros
alimentos
danny y así y si es verdad que se puede
reemplazar entonces estos fertilizantes
por el estiércol bueno no soy yo la
super experta en el tema pero si lo que
he podido investigar es que el estiércol
no es una solución definitiva y expertos
que dicen que por un lado no hay
suficiente estiércol al menos en eeuu
pero además transportarlo es caro y los
precios están subiendo debido justamente
a la alta demanda y también están
altamente regulados por el impacto que
puedan tener sobre los sistemas de agua
sobre eeuu
independientemente de los inconvenientes
la conclusión es que el estiércol es un
nuevo producto bueno daniela vamos ahora
con japón porque anunció nuevas
sanciones contra rusia sí señor prohibió
la importación de carbón ruso para
reducir su dependencia energética como
también lo hizo la unión europea pero
esta es apenas una de varias medidas
adicionales escuchemos las otras y daini
ni eeuu si acá en segundo lugar la
semana que viene introduciremos una
prohibición a las importaciones cosas de
maquinaria cierta madera y vodka tercero
introduciremos medidas para detener
nuevas inversiones en rusia
cuarto fortaleceremos aún más las
sanciones financieras
congelando los activos de los bancos más
grandes de rusia sberbank y alfa bank y
en quinto lugar ampliaremos aún más el
alcance de la congelación de los activos
a personas y empresas
y de japón un lugar tan lejana nos
venimos a nuestra región para resaltar
las noticias económicas claro que si
raúl el banco mundial el redujo su
proyección de crecimiento de este año
para la región de américa latina la
guerra en ucrania la elevada inflación y
la incertidumbre que todavía rodean a la
pandemia llevaron al organismo a situar
su proyección en 23 por ciento desde 2,6
por ciento previsto en enero
en chile por su parte del gobierno de
gabriel brito propuso al parlamento
aprobar un proyecto que eleve el salario
mínimo en 14% de esta manera pasaría de
350 mil a 400 mil pesos chilenos en
dólares esto equivale hoy a unos 500
dólares y el banco central de perú elevó
su tasa de interés a el 45 por ciento
desde el 4% anterior la decisión está
basada en un dramático aumento de los
precios que en los últimos 12 meses
hasta marzo acumularon un 6,82 por
ciento
danny que nos trae como cifra el día
pues hablando justamente de tasas de
interés 17 esta es la nueva tasa de
interés que regirá en rusia el banco
central de ese país decidió bajarla en
tres puntos porcentuales al comienzo de
la guerra cuando comenzó a ser blanco de
sanciones por parte de occidente el
banco central había duplicado este tipo
de intervención hasta el 20 por ciento
ahora dicen que la situación financiera
pues no se ha agravado y uno quejándose
con el 6% y 2000 ya veo era 20 antes de
la guerra ahorita 17 por ciento igual
sumamente alta si se era un 9% antes de
la guerra 20 por ciento le subieron y
ahora bajaron al 17 dios mío bueno dani
muchísimas gracias entonces por toda la
información